you had a 300 plus page production bible
yes can you tell us
when you started assembling that and did
you leave anything out
so yeah the production bible i'd never
compiled anything like this before
other than obviously editing a feature i
guess is a bigger task but
with this film because it was a very
modest budget
and i guess because i
just wanted to drive myself insane i
decided not only was i
directing and shooting it
but i was also going to be doing the
production design
props costumes set dressing
all of that and so i knew if i didn't
have
every detail they're written down i
would lose track
first day into shooting i would have no
idea what shot is next
i would if i just had a shot list i
wouldn't remember like well what was the
composition what would i even think why
was i
you know why did i want to just stay in
close-ups the whole time why didn't i
want to have
so i knew i needed to have it all laid
out so i had all the storyboards
i had all the every scene was broken
down by each shot
in each shot what props were needed what
costumes were needed which actors were
in it which were extras
um vehicles the location everything
broken down
because i knew if i didn't have that you
know
i'd only done one feature before but i
knew in that one there were times where
jared and i would be looking at the
script in the shot list trying to
remember like wait how did that scene
end okay that scene ended in a close-up
so we can't start this one with a
close-up
and we like no wait no no we ended it
with a wide shot so okay we do start
this one with
like trying to figure out the visual
language and i was
you know jared for the longest time was
a crutch for me the guy's just
you know a master of visual storytelling
that i didn't really have to worry about
it much well you know
he's doing big movies now so i was like
well i guess
i'll just shoot this one myself and uh
um but yeah without having him as a
crutch i was really nervous going into
it
and then having so many different
responsibilities creatively on it
uh i had to and i'm so glad i did
because if i didn't have that production
bible this thing would have been a just
a flaming train wreck
so any advice to filmmakers on
how they should begin one maybe it won't
be 300 plus pages but
but but just a a more condensed version
i mean definitely
have all those elements because if
you're if you're doing a lower budget
film you probably don't have somebody
who's a department head for all the
props and adora ahead for costumes and
all that you probably have
if you're lucky of one person that's
overseeing that
sometimes it's just you know everybody's
taking turns on it and you've got actors
bringing their own wardrobe or whatever
but if you do that breakdown you think
about things like okay in this scene
these three guys get bitten by a vampire
so their shirts are going to get bloody
which means i am bringing their shirts
because i'm not paying for their laundry
bills
plus probably won't wash out so knowing
that type of stuff
and then just realizing um you know when
you're doing that when you're doing that
shot list you start thinking about
little things that you wouldn't
necessarily think about like
um there's a scene in it where uh he
throws a cell phone out the window
it was until it was going through really
like putting together this production
bible where i'm like
oh i need to bring a disposable phone i
need to bring a phone that's dead so or
that nobody wants any more
otherwise i guess it'll be my phone we
throw out the window
um so that sort of thing like you know
uh trying to
reach out to friends like hey anybody
got an old cell phone they don't need
anymore
that still powers on um stuff like that
like
i wouldn't have thought of that and so i
highly recommend
putting together not just a shot list
but really some level of production
bible where you know every day when you
walk on the set
you've already gone through a checklist
of the props that you need the costumes
you need
making sure you have the people that you
need um and all sorts of stuff and grant
a lot of that's a producer
you know producer role other department
heads but we just
on this one it was really i mean
michael's an amazing producer and he
handled the logistics well but a lot of
the department heads were
me and other people just kind of putting
our heads together
and so we've got you know nika helped me
as a production coordinator but she's
also acting in
you know quarter of the movie uh you got
sarah as my aed and script supervisor
but she's also acting in part of the
movie
um as well as she's helping jeff black
with sound and she's helping with
getting you know helping michael arrange
food deliveries and all sorts of stuff
like we're all pulled in so many
different directions
the fact that we could all go back to
this production bible and see oh we got
this we've got this this is taken care
of this is checked off
it's a great feeling and there's nothing
like
finishing the day and just seeing
everything on the page checked off
it's the greatest feel in the world like
we got it all we can go to sleep now
so i highly recommend it it's a lot of
tedious work to start with
but it's the most gratifying thing while
you're shooting because
just knowing you've got everything and
be able to check it all off as you
accomplish it
it just gives you peace of mind
and are you just getting like a
three-ring binder yeah and then and then
putting in stuff in these like plastic
um separators yeah it is it's just it's
a three ring binder
um i've got uh basically
each scene has a divider between it so
um when i'm making it that's the other
hard part is like so i made it just in
the order of the script
but then once michael and i had our
shooting schedule down
i reorganized it by day so it's like
okay well we're doing this this day so
that was the tricky part with this one
because
you know certain scenes just like in any
film you break them up this one's being
shot at that part of the day this was
being shot at that part of the day we
hadn't
we had certain scenes that part of them
were shot in laughlin part was shot in
vegas and part was shot in la
so breaking it up by day was also
essential because we'd be like okay on
day
you know once you get to day 20 you know
the script doesn't even mean anything to
you anymore it's all abstract at that
point it's
like you know your brain is just such a
jumbled mess
so you can look at okay on day 20 oh
good okay we're doing the apartment
scene so we don't have to deal with
crowds don't deal with the casino and
deal with that
but you know we've got to make sure we
have the blood bags we've got to make
sure that we have her running shoes and
we have to have this and that
so it just it was uh
it was essential for that and then like
i said just breaking it down
by day was essential too and we just
have a divider between each one
and then outside of course have the pdf
file and i would just each day
print out a couple copies for everybody
to have so that way
you know again checklist uh nika going
through costumes making sure
we had extras costumes and we had the
you know that vania had the right shirt
on that day that matched with the other
scenes and stuff like that so
um yeah i highly recommend keep it as
organized as possible as
thorough as possible again it's tedious
it's a very tedious process i spent
probably as much time playing the
production
bible as i did the first draft of the
script but
it saved me so many times and he helped
just
kept it all organized i didn't have to
think like i could look you see uh
you know right here you've got your uh
shot uh the storyboard
with the shot description underneath it
and you can see all the shots lined up
she's like oh that's why i decided to go
in for a close-up here
because it was described and it made
sense whereas if it just been storyboard
or
shot list it wouldn't have worked for me
now granted
that's if you have you know not
everybody needs storyboards we didn't do
it on fray
partly because oftentimes i would just
defer to jaren on visuals
but you know not everybody needs that
but i feel like the more information you
have the better
because that's one thing i did find was
scary when i was doing fray is that
feeling of forgetting
even what you're doing it's like wait
where are we today
we've shot like four scenes and we're
going into five i don't remember what
this is in the script i remember what i
was trying to accomplish with it
um so yeah i just think it's essential
to have that
you